we start with breaking news and 19 year
old drug dealer has been jailed for life
this afternoon
over the murder of Jody Chesney the
young girl from East London he is one of
two teenagers that have been found
guilty for killing the Rockford
schoolgirl a 17 year old has also been
jailed today for 18 years 17-year old
girl scout Jody was stabbed in the back
in a case of mistaken identity as she
was hanging out with friends in Harold
Hill back in March
most guys Charlotte Lomas was at the Old
Bailey for the sentencing this afternoon
and we could speak to her now and tell
us more about what happened in court not
just the sentencing but the judges
remarks as well Charlotte yes well we
have just heard that 19 year olds Fenton
Unga cui has been given a life sentence
he will serve a minimum term as you said
26 years in prison we also now know that
his 17 year old accomplice who we can
now name as Aaron Isaac's he has been
given an 18 year detention a minimum
term as part of the sentencing the judge
here in court described this attack as
part of a tit-for-tat Vendetta
which was escalating in violence she
described the two men as living in a
world of casual and callous violence she
also said the stabbing was not
spontaneous it involved a degree of
planning now also in court today has
been highly emotional and upsetting day
we've heard 15 victim statements from
friends and family that been read out in
court today reflecting just how many
people's lives have been affected by the
murder of 17 year old Jody Chesney
they've described the pain the emptiness
and the anxiety that's been caused by
her death when she was fatally stabbed
in the back while she was sitting in a
park with friends in March of this year
and the murder which has shocked this
entire country really has brought to the
fore
the impacts of the knife crime in this
country